[Music]
up next a hearing concerning alleged
human rights atrocities occurring in
kuwait the congressional human rights
caucus held the hearing today to
consider reports of violence committed
by iraqi soldiers in kuwait
participants at the hearing include a
representative of amnesty international
and several americans who offer
first-hand accounts of the situation in
kuwait
[Music]
i'd like to um
welcome all of you this morning this is
the
congressional human rights caucus
hearing on the
human rights atrocities in kuwait
we will
begin with
opening statements from
myself and my co-chairman tom lantos
and from the members who are here
and then we will proceed with three
panels of witnesses
who will testify regarding the situation
in kuwait
iraq's invasion of kuwait has dominated
the headlines of our nation's newspapers
for almost two months now
operation desert shield
economic sanctions and other aspects of
the world's reaction to saddam hussein's
horrendous breach of international
boundaries have been examined from
almost every possible perspective
but very little has been reported about
what is actually happening inside kuwait
we are aware that refugees from all over
the world have been filtering out and
that thousands of americans among them
have fled
but there are still thousands of
americans who remain hostage the
majority of which are men not permitted
to leave by iraqi officials
many of these men have been
strategically moved to kuwait's
munitions and chemical producing sites
to be used as a shield against possible
u.s air attacks
in light of sodom hussein's repressive
regime in iraq
it is obvious that kuwaitis and foreign
nationals who remain in kuwait are in
grave danger
since saddam hussein came to power in
1979 any voice of dissent has been
violently suppressed in iraq
the kurds iraq iraq's largest minority
have been brutally and continually
repressed for seeking recognition of
their distinct ethnicity
over the past five years hundreds of
children whose parents were reportedly
political activists have been arrested
and tortured
hundreds of thousands of kurds have been
relocated in efforts to diminish a
collective kurdish presence presence
and hundreds of villages were destroyed
killing thousands by a chemical effect
offensive aimed by iraq against their
own kurdish civilians
with these sorts of egregious violations
having been perpetrated against the
innocent people in saddam hussein's own
country
it is obvious that those opposing iraq's
illegal occupation in kuwait today are
in grave danger
rape destruction and terror rule in
kuwait today
reports are slowly beginning to filter
out of kuwait
stories depicting mass extrajudicial
killings widespread arrests and torture
under interrogation continue to emerge
from the thousands of people who have
fled kuwait
after reviewing iraq's dismal human
rights record and recent reports
outlining conditions in kuwait it is our
duty to ensure the safety of both
foreign nationals held in kuwait and the
citizens of kuwait and neighboring
countries
i would like to thank those testifying
today for their courage
in sharing with us the horrors they saw
firsthand in kuwait
by bringing your testimony to the
attention of congress you are helping
your friends and relatives who remain in
kuwait
like to call now upon my co-chairman
one of congress's outstanding leaders
in fighting for human rights around the
world congressman tom lantos of
california tom
thank you very much
chairman porter
let me say at the outset
that
this is an extraordinary hearing
of the congressional human rights caucus
we have held literally
hundreds of
hearings and meetings and briefings
dealing with human rights violations
around the globe
but we have never dealt
with consummate evil ron amok
as
clearly
as we are dealing with it
this morning
the bipartisan congressional human
rights caucus
has dealt
with violations of human rights
in a tremendous array of countries
running from the soviet union years ago
where our efforts may have played a
small role in the dramatic improvement
of the situation
to human rights violations in tibet
south africa
chile
cuba
dozens of places
in most of these places
we dealt with regimes
which denied
that they were engaged in human rights
violations
one of the remarkable aspects
of saddam hussein's
reign of terror
is that he prides himself
in his human rights
violations he telescopes and advertises
and proudly proclaims
human rights violations he intends to
engage in in the future
the state department report
on human rights around the globe
for the year just ended
calls
human rights
in iraq
as being in an abysmal state
that state department report was issued
prior to the naked aggression
of
saddam hussein
against the sovereign
peaceful
non-threatening
small nation of kuwait
what we have seen since the 2nd of
august
boggles the mind
vast numbers of men women and children
yes children
were killed
executed
by the iraqi regime
premature infants
in incubators
were
sentenced to die
by having the incubators
removed
and the children allowed
to perish
vast numbers
of civilians
have been subjected to the most creative
and imaginative measures of torture
that man's evil mind is capable of
concocting
the world's television screens have seen
the plight of hundreds of thousands of
refugees
most of them very poor people
who after years of hard work
in kuwait
were compelled to leave
leaving their meager resources behind
trying to survive in refugee camps until
they can be evacuated
to their countries of origin
from egypt to bangladesh
the totality of human suffering
that saddam hussein has brought
to hundreds of thousands of human beings
most of them third world people
destitute
poor
desperate
will take years for the civilized world
to comprehend
we should not be surprised at what
saddam hussein has done
because his record clearly indicated the
direction in which he was moving
the use of
poison gas
against his own kurdish citizens some
years ago
which was a subject of a congressional
human rights caucus hearing
the nightmarish pictures on the cover of
newsweek
of piles of bodies of kurdish women and
children
killed by saddam hussein's poisoned gas
attack
on the iraqi village of halabja
populated by kurdish citizens
is one of the most horrendous pictures
to be presented to this world
since the pictures of the holocaust
45 years ago
he is now determined
with his
capability
of chemical biological
and soon nuclear weaponry
to bring untold horror
to this region
it is our purpose
to highlight during the course of this
morning
with the assistance of qualified
witnesses
saddam hussein's human rights record
in kuwait
and to awaken a world
which is still in many ways attempting
to save his face
to provide him an attractive way out
rather than recognizing
that what the world is confronting in
saddam hussein and his regime
is consummate evil
ron amok
i look forward to listening to our
witnesses and i want to thank my friend
and colleague for sharing this hearing
we're joined by
three members of the congressional human
rights caucus and i want to call on each
of them for a brief opening statement as
well
uh buzz lukens of ohio
thank you mr co-chairman i'd like first
of all to complement the co-chairman uh
congressman john porter and of course
the congressman tom lantos
for their aggressive uh handling of the
focusing and the spotlighting of human
rights around the world but especially
today
the
inhuman cruelty is subjected upon the
kuwaiti people by
by a moral [ __ ] a maniacal dictator uh
in in a country that is armed beyond
comprehension
very briefly
it seems as if saddam hussein is willing
to sacrifice
lives and human rights simply to expand
a little evil empire of his own in the
mideast
and i look forward to testimony by first
of all respected ambassador sheikh
al-sabah and of course those people who
lived through this and we're all really
grateful for the hosting and the
sponsoring of this hearing today for
these individuals to tell us firsthand
what really happened
congressman don payne of new jersey
thank you
let me uh
commend both of the chairpersons of the
human rights caucus for calling this
very important
hearing this morning
we can no longer in the 21st century
continue
to have
acts that
happened
years and years ago
things that have happened this year are
similar to things that have happened
six seven
eight nine hundred years ago when
vikings went around europe
uh raiding and pillaging
when the crusades for many years
traveled back and forth
invading and
having destruction in their path and i
think that
the world has grown to a state of
technology
it's a global village interdependence
what happens in one country affects
another
we can no longer live in a world
where we have
aggression
stronger pushing the weaker
people being powerless
and so i believe that
this hearing
hopefully we can
come up with some
rationale and ideas as how we can move
in the future to prevent
these kinds of acts
from happening
and i once again commend the chairperson
for calling this very important meeting
thank you don
finally congressman ron makeley of
rhode island ron
thank you i too would like to commend
the co-chairs for this very timely and i
think very historically important
hearing
this hearing will set the stage for how
we announce to the world what is going
on in kuwait and the devastation which i
believe is occurring to this country
in recent weeks some people have
questioned
why we as the american people got
involved in kuwait some have suggested
it's merely for our own economic
interest to protect our strategic oil
supplies
but the world has stood behind us for a
much more important reason than just
economic and that is that we cannot
permit one country
to so savagely take over another country
and completely begin a systematic
process
of obliterating a people who have lived
on this face of the earth for as long as
the kuwaiti people have lived there if
the news reports are correct we are
hearing that some 60 percent of the
kuwaitis are being systematically moved
out of their country streets are being
redesignated in fact the capital city
has been renamed
what we do here today may set the stage
as i indicated earlier for the next 10
years
we cannot permit human rights to be
violated we cannot permit one country to
sow
violently
and so uh
systematically
destroy another country we must stand
firm against this outrage we cannot as a
civilized leader in this world
permit
such a atrocity to occur for those
kuwaitis who remain in kuwait we must
make sure that they have individual
rights
we cannot permit a country to so
obscure
their fundamental rights which have been
the cornerstone not only of our
constitution here in this country but of
humankind throughout history
as a nation of people we have a duty to
look beyond our own borders to make sure
that individual human rights which is
what this caucus is about are protected
around the world and so mr chairman i
commend you for holding this hearing so
that we can tell the world that this
country will not permit
saddam hussein to take over another
country and decimate the human rights of
its people thank you
i want to thank each of the members of
the caucus for joining our panel this
morning
we will proceed with our first witness
the ambassador of kuwait
his excellency sheikh saud nasir
al-sabah mr ambassador
thank you for joining us
mr chairman
distinguished
congressman
may i first of all
on behalf of
my government
and on behalf of the of my people in
kuwait
express to you
to the congressional human rights caucus
and to the
most of all to the president of the
united states
and to the people of the united states
for the support we've had
since the invasion
of my country by iraq
the support of the united states that
we've had
my view
has cultivated and brought together the
whole world public opinion
in support of our cause
your noble
initiative
to hold this hearing today
is indicative
of the interest
and concern
of the people of the united states
regarding the basic violations
of human rights
by the iraqi occupying power in kuwait
mr chairman we share many values and we
share many views
emanating from the
the u.s bill of rights
when we talk about
life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness
these are the important elements
that my people and the us people share
everyone in the world now is witnessing
the brutality of the iraqi occupying
power over my people
since their unprovoked invasion of my
country on the 2nd of august
they have resorted to the
inhumane
behavior against the people of kuwait
and against other nationalities
especially
the us and western people inside my
country
they have resorted
to acts
of mass executions
they have resorted to mass acts of rape
and they have
resorted to
mass acts of
looting
and pillaging of my country
we have not
in the history of mankind
witnessed
such act of atrocities
by so-called people
as resembled
by the iraqi military occupation of my
country
as you have
so eloquently put it
congressman
and described
the basic violations of human rights
with regard to
the hospitals in kuwait
the schools in kuwait
and the looting of private homes that's
taking place
and the mass destruction
of the infrastructure which we saw
proudly built in the country over the
last 30 years
adding on this
what they had resorted to
to this a complete destruction
of the institutions inside kuwait the
university the schools
people have moved in
for this sole purpose of destroying
human being and destroying
infrastructures
we have repeatedly called
for the humanitarian organizations to be
allowed in
like the red crescent red cross
we have also called for
international correspondence and
international media to be
allowed to go and witness
their atrocities in my country
and repeatedly they have refused and
turned down such requests
and that tantamounts
as evidence
of their
intent to harbor all their acts of
atrocities inside the country
quite recently we've we have seen the
report that came out from amnesty
international
which the factual report
on their
atrocities inside kuwait
today you're going to hear
not hear say evidence
you're going to hear eyewitnesses who
have lived through these atrocities by
the iraqi people
now i do hope
that through you
and through our friends in the united
states
we can all find somehow
any measures
for rescuing my people
and rescuing my mankind
inside the country
as you again have eloquently put it
congressman
the iraqi regime has resorted
to acts of atrocities and mass
executions of their own people
and it's only
again normal for them to do against
other foreigners like us unlike the us
hostages they have there
i do not want to prolong
my opening remarks
as they have been recovered by
by you distinguished gentleman on the
when you
and i will give the chance
an opportunity for you to
address any questions that you have
uh regarding
the human rights violations of the iraqi
occupying power of my country
but again
i must emphasize
the importance of time
i must emphasize the importance of time
time is running out
with the livelihood of my people who
have been deprived of their even basic
foodstuffs
the iraqi army in the last week now have
resorted to the act of looting their
foodstuff from homes
denying medical supplies and medical
care for my people
hospitals are only there to treat iraqi
soldiers and iraqi nationals
the people you see fleeing from kuwait
are people who are in need of medical
care they are forced
to flee their homeland
and you can all understand
how painful it is
to leave your homeland
they have been forced to do so by the
iraqi authorities
with a policy of displacement
and depopulating the country
they are moving in iraqi families to
take over the kuwaiti homes
as you already said you have
also resorted to renaming streets
renaming hospitals renaming the whole
country
such aggression such occupations such
violations
should
and could not stand
in our time
of civilized nations
and i do hope that through you
and through our friends in the united
states
we can find a quick
and prompt solution
in order to rescue my people and to
rescue others in kuwait
i thank you chairman
mr ambassador thank you for your
testimony before we proceed to questions
we also want to welcome to our panel
congresswoman connie marella of maryland
and ask her if she would like to make
any statement
thank you mr chairman
am i on all right with this oh great
good
thank you i i want to commend you and mr
lantos uh two
very distinguished co-chairs of this
human rights caucus for calling this
hearing i this morning just talked to a
friend of mine who is a kuwaitian who
just returned here to the united states
and we discussed the the tenor of this
particular hearing your excellency what
i have to say in an opening statement
picks up on some of the things that you
have already mentioned but i think they
can bear repeating because there's such
atrocities that are taking place
i'm
i'm hoping that
that meetings such as this are really
going to help to focus greater attention
on this issue and help us to gain a more
complete understanding of what's
happening in that part of the world and
our responsibility to each other and
help us to shape our effort to resolve
the problem
the iraqi government of saddam hussein
has denied its citizens their basic
human rights in order to maintain its
dictatorial rule
they've consistently been denied freedom
of expression and association
subject to arbitrary arrest and
imprisonment deportation torture
disappearance
and summary and political execution
iraq's disdain and contempt for human
rights was blatantly expressed by its
use of chemical weapons against the
kurdish minority
the iraqi government is currently
forcibly relocating its kurdish citizens
under a program of such magnitude that
it threatens their ethnic identity and
cultural survival
in the
report country reports on human rights
practices for 1989 the department of
state
reported that quote iraq's human rights
record remained abysmal in 1989
iraq was cited for stifling political
opposition torture summary execution
disappearances and arbitrary detention
also lack of fair trials in addition
iraq has been linked to and supports
various terrorist groups and is on the
state department's list of terrorist
nations
given this history there should be
little surprise about the reports as
sickening and dispiriting as they are
which we're receiving and will be
receiving today about this conduct
of iraqi troops and governing officials
in occupied kuwait
these reports demonstrate and attest to
not only the literal rape of individuals
trapped in kuwait by the iraqi invasion
but also the collective rape of a
country and its people
an entire country is being looted
of almost anything that can be carried
off
including not only such obvious items as
expensive cars and national art
treasures but even traffic lights from
city intersections
while saddam hussein spent his country's
wealth on military hardware in the 1980s
and sacrificed more than one million
iraqi lives in war with iraq kuwait
invested in technological expertise
to serve and improve the well-being of
its people
but little matter
but with the help of his troops
saddam is simply taking for for iraq all
that he's neglected to provide for his
people in the past
perhaps there's been no more sickening
report demonstrating this practice
that those which describe iraqi troops
entering kuwaiti hospitals and
disconnecting newborn babies from
life-sustaining incubators
some reports indicate that babies have
been left on the floor to die as
incubators and other neonatal care
equipment is packed up for transport
back to iraq
amnest amnesty international will be
testifying has taken detailed testimony
from hundreds of people fleeing kuwait
since the iraqi invasion august 2nd
according to amnesty their testimony
builds up a horrifying picture of
widespread arrests
torture under interrogation
summary executions and mass
extrajudicial killings and these
atrocities are not being committed only
against those offering armed resistance
to the occupying forces but also
against men women and children found
with opposition literature
and the kuwaiti flag
or photographs of the emir of kuwait
reports indicate the possession of such
items is punishable by death
i would like to indicate that this is a
real extreme example of man's inhumanity
to man
and i'm reminded of the words of john
dunn who said no man and i know he meant
woman no man or woman is an island we
are all connected to each other and in
that i hope that there will be some
benefit from this hearing and appreciate
not only your excellency being here but
all of the people who are here to share
with us some of the experiences and i
thank the chairman of the committee for
allowing me this opportunity to speak
thank you
thank you very much
we've been joined by two
other members
first a member of the executive
committee of the congressional human
rights caucus congressman jack bigner of
missouri
thank you mr chairman and uh excellency
thank you for being here i know that we
join with you and
in concert with your people both uh
still in kuwait and in exile uh and
hoping that uh justice will prevail and
that they will be restored to legitimate
rule and also to the rights of a free
people
i would thank you for
also giving us the opportunity to
ask you questions and to find out more
about what is truly happening
we are basically
sitting here trying to read news reports
and listen to the
various electronic media and try to sift
through that hopefully you'll be able to
provide us with some information some of
which i'm sure
has not yet been heard but
i know that you
will come away from this meeting knowing
that we stand in solidarity behind the
people whether they're kuwaiti citizens
or they were the various personnel who
were working in kuwait and i and i would
hope that we can get to some of the
plights uh that have been inflicted upon
those individuals uh because that type
of abuse has created refugee situations
in the world that are further
wreaking havoc on the resources of some
countries that i know you would hope
would be very sympathetic to your plight
such as jordan and therefore
there are many things we need to know
but most of all i think you need to know
and convey to your family and to your uh
citizens fellow citizens of kuwait
that we deplore human rights violations
anywhere in the world but especially
those that are at the behest of an armed
aggressor
you jack congressman bob mcewen of ohio
thank you mr chairman and i too
appreciate you giving us this
opportunity to look further behind the
headlines as to the human rights
violations that are taking place in
kuwait your excellency we've met before
and and let me say under very very
adverse circumstances
you are doing an excellent job of
attempting to communicate to the world
those who superficially wish to make
this a battle over oil as i saw on the
evening news last night when they took
people off the street and said this
obviously superficial misunderstanding
of what's at risk here opportunities
such as this are more helpful to
understand this is a question of human
rights this is a question is what do
people believe in what do people stand
for
if if a nation can use its military
might to rape and pillage and destroy
and and civilization and civilized
nations do nothing then we are in for a
bleak period in world history i don't
believe however that is the case and i
believe that the the unification of
nations to stand in support of the
legitimate government of kuwait uh tells
us that while this may be difficult it
is obviously right it has to be done and
i was very disturbed again this morning
to hear a statement on paul harvey news
who in each day has
seemed to have a a decreasing grasp of
what is at risk for the world if we sit
back and allow
those who believe in tyranny to
spread their terror over neighbors
history has shown that you cannot feed
a tyrannical dictator no matter how many
nations you feed him he is not satisfied
and history has shown that if we would
have stopped at one uh in times past uh
perhaps if we would have drawn the line
immediately rather than waiting for four
or five nations uh many lives could have
been saved and the world could have been
spared a great deal of terror i think in
this case is exactly the the same
analogy that this has to be stopped the
line has been drawn kuwait must be free
it must be independent and
anything less than that would do
civilization and the world a disservice
and so therefore we stand united with
you and and wish you well in the effort
that you are undertaking to communicate
to the world that this is a question of
human rights of civilization versus
anarchy and it has to be made here now
thank you very much congressman mcewan
uh questions for the ambassador
i have a couple of questions
mr ambassador
i would like to ask you because you are
the focal point of information coming
out of kuwait
whether
the information
that we have through amnesty
international and other sources
corresponds to the information you have
specifically on the following items
it is my understanding
that there has been
a very large number
of executions
in kuwait
by the invading iraqi military forces
do you have any estimate of the number
of individuals who were killed
since august 2nd
either kuwaiti citizens or others who
were living in kuwait by the iraqi
authorities
uh congressman
lantos
i think i mentioned in my
opening remarks
that because of the iraqi refusal to let
people in kuwait
humanitarian organizations or foreign
correspondents
to witness such atrocities
information coming out to us
is very sporadic
we do have some line of communications
with kuwait
where we get first-hand information on
daily basis what's going on
to answer the question yes there has
been mass execution of kuwaitis who were
not just involved in the resistance but
who were even suspected
of being involved in the resistance
last week there was a mass execution of
21
university professors
who refused
to open up the university
and who refused to take down the picture
of the emir and replace it by the
the picture of saddam hussein
and for that reason they were executed
summarily by the iraqis
there are other executions taking place
it's difficult for us to document
but i know many friends of mine been
executed i know many relatives of mine
were executed and i know many other
nationalities have been executed
for not cooperating with the iraqi
invasion
there have been egyptians that have been
asians and others
and
it's very difficult for us unless there
is
a supervisor
or supervision inside kuwait to know
exactly what is going on but from the
report we're getting the answer to your
question yes there is a mass execution
taking place
but some in some places in open areas
and some places undercover
mr ambassador we we fully realize that
your your information is fragmentary
are we talking about
dozens of people are we talking about
hundreds of individuals who have been
executed to the best of your knowledge
congressman i'm here testifying and i
want to be as correct and as truthful as
i could be
you could be talking about
hundreds
you could be right
but the numbers the numbers we have been
mis missing in kuwait
that have been reported to us by their
families
were able to fled kuwait or are still
inside kuwait they're reporting they're
missing we know many of them have
already been executed many have been
detained and taken to iraq for further
interrogation and imprisonment and
harassment
me ask you a question about the tortures
that we
are getting information about and see if
this corresponds with your information
we have been advised that there has been
rape on an indiscriminate and massive
scale
there has been the most brutal torture
of both men women and children
with prolonged beatings on the most
sensitive parts of the human body
the extraction of fingernails and
toenails electric shock
are these the kinds of reports you are
getting
yes sir they are the kind of reports
that i am getting all the above all the
ones you have mentioned we are getting
the reports and we have had also now
some victims of these tortures that are
now in saudi arabia and are now in egypt
also who have there had
women that have had their nails pulled
out and they've been subjected to
electric
shocks and etc
the torture you described
sir is what has being done by the iraqis
all during the invasion and still
continue to do it throughout
final question i have
in some ways for the long run
has the most sinister implications
it is my understanding
that there is a forcible
mass displacement
of the kuwaiti population
by
iraqis
loyal to saddam hussein
in anticipation of saddam hussein at
some point
calling for a plebiscite
which then
would
take place
with
kuwait's own people no longer able to
vote in an election
presenting the world with the phony
result
that individuals living in kuwait
want to see the absorption of kuwait
by iraq
this is a
an attempt to obliterate
an independent and sovereign nation
is this basically
what on the basis of your information is
happening mr ambassador
congressman lentes
what iraq would resort to
and by to any means
i think are
unpredictable by anyone
this i've heard as a possibility
by this policy of displacement
that saddam hussein will one day turn
around and have a deficit inside kuwait
and say this is the wish of the kuwaitis
we all know as you have quite rightly
put it
that this policy of displacement might
lead to such phony procedures or they
might resort to such funny procedures
but we must be quite aware of it
that such things such laws by the iraqis
they have resorted to since their
invasion
of this
ploy or this phony government they they
installed and then
this government came by and
wanted a unity with iraq thereby
annexing kuwait and etc as we've heard
in the past
such flaws and and and phony measures
are within the anticipation of the iraqi
regime and we must be
quiet and ready uh
to face it because as you quietly said
this this will not do not stand so
perhaps the occasional opening up
of the kuwaiti saudi border
to allow kuwaiti citizens to leave
is really not a humanitarian gesture
but it is a
sinister plan designed
to diminish
the indigenous kuwaiti population within
cuvette is that correct you're quite
right uh congressman in saying so this
is the attempt on the part of iraqis and
when they opened the borders in the
south of saudi arabia
and allowed people to get out
they also
stripped them of all their identities
with all the from the all the valuables
and they took everything with them and
they had only the clothes on their backs
which they left in the country we are
concerned about all the forged documents
and identities that the iraqis have from
the kuwaitis in
fulfilling this kind of policy of
displacement which i refer to my opening
remarks and i agree with you entirely
that this could be another iraqi ploy
they're trying to play in allowing
kuwaitis is far far from a humanitarian
kind of measure they are again doing
this in order to stake out
certain kuwaitis who they wanted to
arrest
officials who are in the security or in
the army and when families attempt to
leave the border in the south
they allow women and children and they
interrogate the men
men between the ages of 15 to say 40 to
see whether they are wanted by the iraqi
regime whether they have been involved
in resistance movement whether they are
in the kuwaiti security or on the army
if they are proved to be uh to be so
they are detained and they disappear we
don't know we have hundreds
of of kuwaitis we cannot account for
they've been taken to iraq all young
people between the age of 15 to to 40
in that range so your conclusion is
quite right in in in your founding
thank you thank you thank you mr
chairman
other questions for the ambassador
mr lukens
mr chairman i have one question mr
ambassador if i might
uh along the lines of the economic rape
of your country
how long do you think it will be
given the fact that we're almost 70 days
into the occupation
before the iraqis have basically
taken everything of economic value and
of technology technological value of
educational value
from your country we know the reports
are
substantially substantiated now that
they have removed such things as the
traffic lights
all hospital equipment
they've
totally removed all equipment from
universities and schools
could you elaborate on that a bit and
just give some kind of time
estimate of your timetable
for the total removal of everything of
economic value physically from your
country
uh congressman lukens
what they have done already in removing
materials from kuwait that were
accomplished from all public
institutions
the central bank of kuwait has been
emptied
all the banks in kuwait have been
emptied all the public buildings the
government offices departments have been
emptied schools university hospitals
anything which is not nailed down
have been taken away and even if it is
nailed down it's removed
our concern here everything is
replaceable
this could be replaced in time our
concern here is for human lives and
violation of human rights
this is really our concern here
everything in material i mean despite
and the greed of the iraqis
this could be replaced in due time by us
with the help of our friends
we are concerned here with the
well-being of the the kuwaiti people and
others who are inside kuwait and this is
why
i've re-emphasized the importance of
time here is that
if they are deprived of their food staff
they are deprived of medical care how
long could those people survive under
terror under oppression by the iraqis
psychological warfare in the media
inside kuwait the tv inside kuwait
they have also university hospitals
anything which is not nailed down have
been taken away and even if it is nailed
down it's removed
uh our concern here everything is
replaceable
this could be replaced in time our
concern here is for human lives and
violation of human rights
this is really our concern here
everything in material i mean despite
and the greed of the iraqis
this could be replaced in due time by us
with the help of our friends
we are concerned here with the with the
well-being of the the kuwaiti people and
others who are inside kuwait and this is
why
i re-emphasize the importance of time
here is that
if they are deprived of their food staff
they are deprived of medical care how
long could those people survive under
terror under oppression by the iraqis
psychological warfare in the media
inside kuwait the tv inside kuwait
they have also
jammed
foreign radios like voice of america or
the bbc or try to jam it in order that
people's people inside kuwait cannot get
the correct right reports from broad
there is no communication with it with
the outside world
so in in essence they are isolated
inside
and the iraqis are doing what they're
doing to the people in complete
isolation from world public opinion
thank you vegeta are there questions for
the ambassador
ron makeley a member of the executive
committee
thank you uh your excellency based on
reports that you have received
are you able to make any conclusion
whether or not our
economic embargo will have the desired
effect
prior to the decimation of your country
of having
saddam hussein withdraw into iraq and if
so would that be necessarily a desired
solution
and if you feel that the economic
embargo will not work
is it better that we use military force
sooner than later
congressman um
my view is on the sanctions
and the economic embargo
on iraq
as implemented by the security council
to force iraq with a view of forcing
iraq out of kuwait
allow me respectively to disagree on
this fact
i don't believe personally that
iraq
in the short run or the long run
will be adversely affected by these
sanctions
knowing iraq iraq is a big country
iraq is an agricultural country
they can sustain themselves indefinitely
with food staff
can sustain themselves with all other
needs of the iraqi people
the iraqi regime now is
providing food for their military and
for their party
and the iraqi people come third and then
my people inside kuwait have nothing
after they have
robbed all the foodstuffs from kuwait
and they've shipped it back to iraq or
trucked it back to iraq
there are plenty of supplies plus what
they grow inside iraq
the borders with jordan is still open
there are hundreds of trucks
coming in from jordan to iraq
even with the air embargo that has been
imposed now on iraq by the recent
security council resolution
is being violated indirectly because
flights come into amman jordan
they unload into trucks
and they go into iraq
so in
in concluding i would reach the
following conclusion
sanctions and embargo on iraq will not
and i repeat will not
bring iraq down on its knees to force it
out of kuwait
the other
factor involved here you might ask
is that there is an embargo on all
shipments from iraq therefore iraq
cannot sell oil therefore they cannot
get hard currency
and i will have my answer on this too
because iraq has some allies that are
providing iraq with funds
with which to withstand the sanctions
and the embargo
therefore in in in
to finalize this whole thing i would
reach the conclusion that neither in the
short run in the long run iraq will
will be
forced out of kuwait because of their
sanctions and i think what was said by
the iraqi foreign minister two days ago
reaffirms this this fact and he said
that
they will not be affected by it and they
will continue to defy it
further questions congressman bigner yes
thank you uh john ambassador
to expand on that a little bit you said
that uh iraq has allies that are
providing it with uh hard currency uh is
that through loans are they acquiring
the oil and who are we talking about you
talk about iran um
um
this is a public hearing uh congressman
i don't wish to get into uh
sensitive information on this
but we have witnessed and we have seen
certain movements of funds
through central banks and other
countries who are providing credit lines
for iraq and hard currencies
to enable them to further buy spare
parts and other needs for the iraqi army
and by the by the way the the
reports that you've been hearing that
iraq imports 80 percent of food stuff i
can't really
um
find any justification just reports you
know the um
iraq is self-sustained in in their
foodstuff what they import are luxuries
coming in from other different countries
and
if you wish after the ceiling i could
provide you with the information where
the funds are moving from different
central banks that providing credit
lines for iraq yes excellency i think
that the members of the committee would
uh
very much like to have that confidential
briefing with you and i thank you very
much i yield back
congresswoman marilla thank you just
briefly um your excellency what kind of
communication do you have with the
people in kuwait um how does that
operate how do you get your reports and
the daily communication i don't wish to
discuss this in a public hearing i think
that's not sensitive
the other the other part was to pick up
on the question my colleague had asked
too in terms of
the possibility of military force do you
want to comment on that or is that
too sensitive i intentionally avoided
commenting on it i think
congressman mctelly knows
what my answers were leading to and you
could reach your own conclusions
i mean we are interested at some point
maybe not even now for your opinion
about the role of the united states and
the united nations and in this i'm sure
you've shared it with our state
department but um might be of some
interest to us to hear too from yes i am
in my opening statement i did um
mention this fact the role of the united
states
used to be the role of united nations
and and i said that
for your benefit what i said is that
the the us position has cultivated the
united nations and cultivated the whole
world the world public opinion behind
kuwait
and
i would have a chance to discuss other
matters that you have touched upon maybe
at another opportunity thank you
congressman don payne
your excellency
the
what is your
feeling and you don't have to answer
this if you feel it shouldn't be
of the
of um
the role that king hussein of jordan had
played
and
how important
do you feel
that cooperation from jordan is
if one we are going to attempt to have
the
embargo although you feel that the
embargo is not necessarily the way to
to go
how important is it is it to
have the full cooperation if that's
possible from king hussein
uh congressman payne i think the
major loophole we have here
with the implementation of the full
effectiveness of the sanctions
the loophole here we have is jordan
which is still the borders are open
although they declare that
they respect and implement the sanctions
we don't see any proof of that we don't
see an indication of that
the borders with iraq are open
and the
foodstuff and other luxury items and
maybe spare parts are being trucked in
from jordan to iraq
so i would
not agree with what they have said
regarding their implementation sanctions
and this is the major loophole we have
now that the borders with jordan are
still open and iraq is
getting what they need through these
borders so um
they claim that they are uh
honor the sanctions is uh completely
unfounded in our views
thank you bob mckeon mr ambassador
obviously uh saddam hussein has
intelligence sources that tell what the
united nations
are up to in uh
surrounding this country what is your
analysis of what his next move will be
should
the preparations
for the defense of your country be
completed within the next three to four
weeks by the united nations
i don't personally think that saddam
hussein will do anything
saddam hussein's policy now
would be to
sit tight where he is
in a defensive posture
to strengthen his grip upper kuwait
in an attempt
to outlast the patients
of the multinational forces that are in
saudi arabia now
especially the united states
he hopes
to break this alliance
whether with the multinational forces or
the united nations
he believes that his time
is on his side
he could sit there
and
outlast
in his belief outlast
your patient and others
thereby accomplishing his mission
i don't think saddam hussein will resort
to any provocation because he's heard it
so many times from the u.s
that no military action will be
conducted until there is provocation
now
he could read between the lines
now if he reaches that conclusion
there will be no provocation on his side
he will sit tight
he would not resort to any other means
like the electric we've heard regarding
um
uh
sending missiles into israel and et
cetera et cetera these are rhetorics and
he will just sit tight and outlast you
that's what he intends to do
if the united states were to threaten to
to make a move uh at any time what would
his reaction be at that point and can
you speculate on that
what would his reaction be
i think not just i'm not concerned with
what his reaction will be we can
understand what his reactions will be
the
i'm quite sure that the reaction of the
iraqi people themselves
will be so
welcoming
for any
military action against their regime
to get the iraqi
people freed from this
tyranny of a regime over them by doing
so my friend you're not just relieving
the whole area from this
dictator
you're relieving also the iraqi
civilians iraqi people who have been
under his dictatorship for so many years
thank you very much
mr ambassador thank you very much for
being with us this morning and thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
very much and i appreciate it thank you
would our second uh panelists please
come up and be seated at the table
that is uh miriam allahi and dr hassan
el ibrahim
i'm going to ask each of them to
present their testimony before we ask
questions
of both of them
and
let me begin by introducing mrs miriam
illahi
she is the government program officer
for north africa the middle east and
europe for amnesty international
an amnesty has just concluded a
fact-finding mission to bahrain
where they interviewed victims and
eyewitnesses of human rights abuses in
kuwait and we welcome you this morning
miriam
thank you chairman lanceos chairman
porter distinguished congressmen and
women for that pull the microphone close
to you and speak right into it
for this opportunity to testify before
the congressional human rights caucus i
would like to briefly describe some of
the human rights abuses being committed
by the iraqi army in kuwait a more
detailed testimony
which includes amnesty's long-term
concerns on the widespread and
systematic violations of human rights by
the iraqi regime inside of iraq is
contained in my written testimony which
is being submitted for the record
hundreds of people are believed to have
been arrested in kuwait by iraqi forces
since august 2nd
refugees fleeing kuwait have told
amnesty international that iraqi forces
have arrested men women and even
children for possessing opposition
literature the kuwaiti flag or
photographs of the amir of kuwait
people are said to have been arrested
and in some instances killed for their
non-violent opposition to the iraqi
invasion including the failure to
demonstrate the proper allegiance to the
iraqi president saddam hussein
amnesty international has received
numerous reports of the routine torture
of detainees
by the iraqi security forces
victims have suffered rape
electric shocks
prolonged beatings to sensitive parts of
their bodies the breaking of their arms
and legs
and the pulling out of their finger and
toenails
others have been summarily executed
iraqi forces have reportedly killed
scores of unarmed civilians
boys as young as 15 have been shot in
the head and their bodies dumped outside
their houses in the streets
in one incident in kuwait city iraqi
soldiers reportedly fired at a group of
35 women and children who were
peacefully protesting iraq's annexation
of kuwait
an eyewitness told amnesty that two boys
aged 13 and 16 and a 20 year old girl
were killed by bullets in the head and
heart
amnesty international calls upon the
iraqi government to immediately end all
extrajudicial executions summary
killings acts of torture and arbitrary
arrests thank you
thank you very much next dr hassan
al-ibrahim
president of the citizens for a free
kuwait
he will provide a statement and then
introduce a brief video featuring
footage that was recently filmed in
kuwait dr abraham ibrahim thank you very
much for being with us and members of
the committee
allowed me to introduce myself
please please speak right into the
microphone
if you can put it right in front of you
i am hassan ibrahim
i am the former director of kuwait
university
and more recently the former minister of
education in kuwait
i am a founding member of the arab
organization for human rights
and for three years i have been member
of this organization's board of trustee
i am presently the chairman of kuwait
society for the advancement of arab
children
and president of the new organization
united states citizen for free kuwait
established after the iraqi invasion of
august second
in conjunction with the society for the
advancement of arab children and is the
only society in the arab world sir
ten days ago
i had an interview with the voice of
america
which was in arabic
and i have talked about the atrocity
committed by saddam hussein in kuwait
two days ago
a friend of mine who was able to get out
of kuwait
told me that as a result of my interview
the society was ransacked
fax machines were stolen
telephone were stolen
computer were stolen
and the only thing untouched fortunately
sir the library
because we have a section
that documents human rights violation
of saddam and iraq
the library fortunately was not touched
before august 19
before august 2nd 1990 the human rights
record of the state of kuwait has been
one of the best in the world
as attested by all respected independent
human rights organization and the us
department of estate
all these changes with saddam hussein
invasion of kuwait in august second
and this conjunction sir please allowed
me
to read four articles of kuwait
constitutions
part three under the heading of public
rights and duties
article 29 stated
all people are equal in human dignity
and public rights
and duties before the law without
distinction as to race origin language
or
religion
article 30 sir
personal liberty
is
guaranteed article 31st
no person shall be arrested detained
searched or compelled to reside in a
specified place
nor shall the resident of any person or
his liberty to choose his place of
residence or his liberty of movement be
restricted
except in accordance with provision of
law
no person shall be subjected to torture
or to degrading
treatment
article 34
an accused person is presumed innocent
until proved guilty in a legal trial to
which the necessary guarantee for
exercise the right of defense are
secured
the inflection of physical or moral
injuries in an accused person is
prohibited
sir this article have been observed in
kuwait
since the introduction of the
constitution and before that
i appear
before you ladies and gentlemen
and it's sad in my heart to present the
following example of iraqi human rights
violation in kuwait
this have been confirmed by the cfk and
by amsterd international
execution
and murder
rape
use of electrical shocks
prolonged beating to sensitive parts of
the body
breaking limbs
pulling hair with pincers
pulling out fingers and toenails
psychological threat of sexual assault
or execution
those who oppose the iraqi occupation
neither been executed
either been executed tortured or thrown
into prison
humanity should not stand idle
while saddam hussein the butcher of
baghdad systematically continue in his
bloody
path
for erasing kuwait identity from the bab
rest assured ladies and gentlemen this
shall never
never
never happen
kuwait and its people shall prevail
as we shall restore human rights and
dignity to our country once again
sir by the end of my statement allowed
me to introduce
or show to you this video tape that we
have received
the horror of the iraqi atrocity is best
seen through the eyes of those who
witness and experience it firsthand
this videotape will show
the eyewitnesses
who have seen in their own eyes what
happened in kuwait
the iraqis killed five little kids
without even conducting any
investigation
they killed them because they had some
literature
that says long live the emir
iraqis broke into a respectful man's
gathering room
this man happened to be a preacher who
also gave religious lessons to the
kuwaiti children
the iraqis accused him of being a member
of the resistance force
so they imprisoned him
ten days later this man came to us and
his body was burned
then the iraqis took him to his house
and shot four bullets into his head
right in front of his mother
the banners of kuwait
and children were also accompanying them
children at the age of three and four
were carrying the banners five children
randomly including three
with their
heads completely torn apart and their
brains can be seen of course they died
immediately and two were shot in their
chest and abdomen
we exerted our utmost but these savage
shooting of the iraqi soldiers of saddam
hussein did not allow us the chance
there were two kuwaiti young men in it
the iraqi soldiers stopped them
we were right behind them
inside their car the soldiers found
identification cards indicating that the
two kuwaiti young men
were members of the national guard or
perhaps affiliated with the kuwaiti
forces
there were approximately 12 or 13 cars
detained
waiting to be searched
the iraqi soldiers pulled the two
kuwaiti young men out of their car they
pulled them right
out before our eyes
there were children in the other cars
the iraqi soldiers had the two kuwaiti
young men stand in the middle of the
road and shot them before everybody's
eyes
the bodies would be left in the streets
until they rot
they prevented any car from carrying the
buddies to the hospital to be placed in
refrigerators or to be buried
they stole the patient's food and went
into the nurse's residence under the
pretext that they were providing
security when in fact they raped the
nurses
there's a second at this residence
after a few hours
of the storming because they had run
away with any clothes they had on
to the hospital there were attempts of
rape
for the
nurses
the egyptian nurses and other
nationalities from iraqi soldiers and
i'm a witness to this particular
incident
hospital and took five
nurses to rape them
luckily gunfires were hurt outside the
residence so the soldiers
ran away in case it may be resistant
[Music]
when i was leaving kuwait i had my sick
little baby with me
the iraqis refused to let me take my
sick child
they said he was less than a year old
and i had to leave him here when i
begged the soldier to let me take my
sick baby they tried to pull him out of
my arms they ridiculed me to the point
that i cried when i cried even more they
laughed at me
when they brought my mentally [ __ ]
sister to us
they told us that if you cannot feed her
we can take her back to baghdad with the
rest of the mentally [ __ ]
and put a bullet in each of them
the treatment of
the chronic cases stopped cancer
cases
were brought out of the hospital
and
unfortunately most of them died
the
deformed children
of course were evacuated also and died
in short
medical care in kuwait
is deteriorating continuously
she was driving her car with her clothes
in a convoy of course
in an area between bertad and the
fallujah i share with
the brave iraqi soldiers the heroes of
the arabic nation and the protectors of
the eastern
gate of the arab nation they went out to
her with
their knives
attacked her took the cars and dropped
her left in the street
all alone until another car with an
egyptian family picked her up and wrote
her back
i got shot on the first day of the
invasion as i was going to work
as i was passing by the conference
palace i saw a soldier and he shot me in
my head
and one of the bullets broke
and shattered a window
near me
and the other bullet went through the
rear window
the iraqis abducted a man at the salmia
police station
because he had an audio cassette of the
emir speech and the speech of sheikh
ahmed al-gathan a religious preacher
they took his 15 year old daughter
upstairs and raped her brutally and then
returned her to her father
once they attacked the supermarket
took all the men and women out
killed the men in front of the woman
the method of shooting the men was to
prolong their suffering
as soon as the iraqis came in
they entered the hospitals
and the first thing they did
they went to the intensive care units
for the extremely sick and remove the
tubes
and the equipment for the heart patients
and of course the patient died
immediately
some people went to their workplace
soldiers for example
they just
disappeared they never came home again
one of our friends went to ask about his
son he saw a group of his son's friends
there the next day when he went back
another thing happened
they went into the house of some friends
of ours and they asked where is uh
so and so
when they discovered that the person
wasn't there they took the nearest
relative to him
this happened at the beginning of the
occupation and until this day they
haven't heard anything from them
i can tell you an example they took two
of my relatives
two boys
one seventeen and one sixteen years old
for having a pamphlet in their car
and continue to torture them for three
days with no food and no water
[Music]
it was as if a gang has entered the
country and had a limited time say one
hour to steal as much as they can
they took everything they found
the country turned into a wasteland
i
want to thank our two witnesses i want
to ask you to stay at the witness table
and be joined by the next panel
and then we'll after they testify we'll
have questions perhaps for all of you is
that uh
permissible thank you
will the panelists from panel three
please come and join them at the table
i believe there are enough seats
[Music]
well i've just i've just been informed
we have
a number of addition two additional
witnesses to join uh to join the two
that are there i hope we have i guess we
do have enough chairs i'm gonna call on
each of them uh for their testimony
before we ask uh questions first
ruth al
khalaf
an american
born married to a kuwaiti mr chairman
and members of the committee my name is
ruthie shafer al-gallah
i'm very pleased and honored to
participate
in this hearing and to give you a first
hand perspective on the iraqi atrocities
in kuwait
i thank you mr chairman for calling
worldwide attention to these brutal
crimes
i'm an originally from memphis tennessee
i am married to a kuwaiti air force
major
we met at memphis state in 1978
and when he completed his studies he
asked me to join him in kuwait to start
our life together
i was able to meet to be among the first
group of hostages to leave kuwait on
september 7th with my three children
at that time in 1978 when i went to
kuwait
kuwait the society was less westernized
than it is today
however my cultural transition was eased
by the warmth and support of my
husband's family and the expatriate
community with which i worked i was
employed by kuwait institute for
scientific research
where women had the opportunity to work
at all levels
it has been one of the most prominent
research institutes in the middle east
specializing in water resources
mariculture and fisheries environmental
science and petroleum
now i'd like to tell you about the
kuwait that i knew and loved
a kuwait that was filled with the hustle
and bustle of everyday life
cars driving everywhere people in the
streets and the markets visiting each
other the atmosphere in kuwait was very
easy going
the kuwaitis who are very gentle and
warm people made people
made one feel at ease immediately
we never locked our doors to our homes
or to our cars we always felt safe
your privacy was always respected
since the iraqi invasion kuwait is a
mere shadow of the once vibrant country
everyone
fears the the the panic and desperation
in everyone's faces is something i'll
never forget
i was so afraid to leave my home i would
only leave if it was absolutely
necessary to go out and get food
or to travel from one house to another
when we heard that the iraqis were in
our area and we were literally fleeing
for our lives house to house
we locked our doors sometimes we slept
on the floors
we were afraid to speak on the
telephones as if you spoke after two
minutes they would trace the call and
come to your house if they heard a
western voice on the phone i lived in a
state of constant terror and anxiety not
knowing if the iraqis were going to
break down my door in the middle of the
night to
rape me torture my children or take my
loved ones from me
i was so petrified that i used to sleep
with my curtains open a little bit so i
could wait until the morning light would
come so i'd realized that i had made it
through
another night
the iraqis have systematically destroyed
the kuwait that i came to know and love
the modern high-rise hotels and
government buildings have been reduced
to ashes and soot
schools and government buildings and
hospitals have been stripped bare
all of the desks the blackboards the
books the hospital beds the medical
equipment the medicine the life
supporting equipment have all been
stolen by the iraqis
even before i left kuwait a little more
than a month after the invasion
this peaceful country has been turned
into an iraqi military installation
there's an iraqi tank about every 300
yards on the waterfront road which is
called the gulf road
every neighborhood is occupied by at
least 50 to 100 if not more iraqi
soldiers whose behavior is very
unpredictable depending on their mood
we lived under constant threat of
physical brutality
for example a friend of our families who
worked at kuwait airways was out after
the curfew which at that time was seven
o'clock
the soldiers picked him up and broke his
back in three places they beat him so
hard unnecessarily
the terror we lived was unbelievable the
sister of a friend of mine
who was kuwaiti was heading toward the
border when they opened the borders in
saudi arabia with her
mother and her brother and her one and a
half month old baby she was holding in
her arms
when she arrived at the border the
soldier iraqi soldier asked her is that
a male or a female child
she said this is my son he said give him
to me we've been ordered to kill all
male children
she said kill us all kill everybody in
the car but you're not taking my baby
she tell the soldier you're not a father
you don't have a mother you don't know
what it feels to to lose a child
and
the iraqi soldier actually let them go
the story gives me the chills every time
i think of that moment of terror for
that poor woman
at the border
men from 15 to 35 years old were forced
out of their cars
and taken away some of some never to be
seen again
in a society where men are instrumental
to the social and cultural fabric this
act alone can completely debilitate
kuwaiti women
however in spite of their gentle nature
the kuwaiti women are quite strong
they will overcome these loathsome
experiences inflicted upon them by the
iraqis but at a great personal and
psychological
cost
iraqis have contempt have attempted to
control the kuwaitis by threatening to
kill their families
as well as their neighbors if they don't
do as they like
for example five iraqi soldiers were
found dead in an area in kuwait in a
certain neighborhood
and as a result
they went in and looted and robbed the
houses and and burned the homes
the cousin of a kuwaiti friend was a
military officer in kuwait and he was in
hiding he went home just
to change his clothes and was there five
minutes they picked him up
they tortured him
they abused him and after ten days of
torture they brought him to his parents
home
called out all of the family members the
neighbors and shot him dead in front of
his mother
and then they burned the mother's house
iraqi soldiers are taking young kuwaiti
girls aged 13 14 and 15 and raping them
the physical horror of this speaks for
itself
however in this society where virginity
is a prerequisite for marriage it is
even more devastating for these poor
girls
a girl who is not a virgin brings shame
on herself and on her family
a friend of my husband's heard of a man
who had both of his ears cut off
until he revealed the name of 15 people
who were in the resistance movement and
then those 15 men were found dead and
slaughtered
it is a normal iraqi practice to
arbitrarily arrest 50 to 75 kuwaitis
each afternoon and throw them into the
jails in each neighborhood where they
are tortured and humiliated
and urinated on and forced to consume
their own
feces they are interrogated and if the
soldiers do not like what they say they
shoot them
rather than allowing the kuwaitis to
bury their dead
the iraqis dump the bodies on an ice
skating rink near kuwait city
this was the first place that you would
look if your relatives would come up
missing your brother or your father
you would go to the ice skating rink and
look through the bodies to find your
relative
the iraqi soldier
respect for human life seems so
negligible that they make bets on how
many breaths a kuwaiti will take between
the time he is shot and the time he dies
i want to be happy to be back here in
the united states but i feel empty and
devastated
i think of the suffering of the kuwaiti
people and all other nationalities i
left behind in kuwait
after what i've witnessed i don't know
if i'll ever be truly happy or settled
again
my children are so worried about their
father
they ask me if there's a school that
they can go to that will teach them how
to pray to get their prayers answered
i always say no that god will hear their
prayers
wherever they are and just to keep
praying for daddy's well-being
thank you
ruth thank you very much
several of our witnesses
are
concerned that their families may
receive retribution if their identity is
revealed and we want to ask
our friends in the media to respect
their wishes in this regard
our next witness is using
an assumed name
we will call him abdullah
and ask him next to testify
[Music]
mr chairman members of the of the
committee
i was in kuwait when the invasion took
over
and as as a lawyer kuwaiti citizen i
make i made contact with the military
to to express my willingness
to contribute or to to volunteer in the
army
but they asked me to stay where i'm
where i was
because
at that time
the baracks were surrounded by the
iraqis
and they could be shot by the iraqis or
mistakenly by the kuwaitis
i i stayed in quite seven weeks almost
seven weeks
under the uh
under the
the invasion
and consisting of doing my part to
contribute the recovery of my country
i cannot discuss
all of these things for fear of reprisal
against my family members
who are still in kuwait
or
compromising the ongoing
efforts of the resident
resistance
however i will share a few accounts of
the atrocities witnessed in kuwait after
the august second invasion
while at the market
trying to buy food for my family
i saw two kuwaiti young boys
15 or 16 years old
in handcuffs
escorted by iraqi soldiers
and the soldiers
knocked on the door escorted to a house
and the soldiers knocked on the door and
a child answered
they asked
her
to call her mother or father
and when the the women came out
they asked her to to identify or if she
knew these two boys she said yes they
are my sons
then the soldiers asked her to come out
and to call all family members to go to
come out of the house
and when they gathered outside the house
they instructed the two young
boys
to stand off the wall
and in full view of the mother
sister and young brother
and as well as around 50 million
women
in the marketplace
they shot and killed the two boys
no kuwaiti has accepted the invasion of
our country
all have found ways
to resist the systematic destruction of
our country
young boys has joined the resistance
women and girls
have distributed flyers and leaflets
kuwaiti have housed and protected
westerns in their house
at great risk
kuwaiti have refused to renounce their
pride
in country
their identity
and the religious beliefs
three days before i escaped
i participated
in a funeral of my
friend he was a religious man
he was tortured and killed
his fingernail extracted
his beard
has ripped off
of his chin
because of what because he delivered the
speech
in a friday religious ceremony
condemning the iraqi invasion of kuwait
the iraqi soldiers after two days
searched and found him
like i say they tortured him and killed
him
and his body was deposited near the
mosque
where he delivered the speech
kuwaiti men injured in defending
their freedom
the restoration of the restoration of
our sovereign
territory
and legitimate government
cannot safely go safely go to the
hospital
for treatment
they must seek shelter
and mythical attention
in homes of of those they trust
this they are subject
for primitive
care medical care
from volunteers doctor volunteers
who risk their lives
just to take for to take to care for
them
they often die of wounds
which otherwise can successfully
treated
i on him to i am here today mr chairman
to tell you that the fight
is still going on
in kuwait
under great personal risk
while i number myself
among those fortunate to manage to
escape from
kuwait without injury
and to be able to continue my resistance
outside kuwait
my heart
like those of my family
and my friends
remains within kuwait
i salute
american people
to their position
to their support
and they have the i hope they continue
supporting us
in fights
against tyranny
tyranny and terror
and i witnessed
a catastrophe things
which was happened in my country
like i said i cannot reveal
i cannot
say all of this
just to protect my family members and my
friends who are still in kuwait thank
you mr chairman
sir we
thank you for your willingness and your
courage and and the willingness and
courage of all of our witnesses and in
testifying
this morning
next deborah
hadid
american born married to a kuwaiti
mr chairman and members of the committee
my name is deborah hoddy and i
appreciate very much
the microphone right there yeah
i appreciate very much to be here today
to share with you some of my thoughts
and feelings regarding the terrible
events that have taken place in kuwait
i met my kuwaiti husband here in the
united states when we were both
attending the university of louisville
i've spent the last 12 years in kuwait
we had a wonderful life we've seen a lot
of the world
but now i'm afraid for my husband's life
and the life we once had together
i'm afraid i'll never be able to go home
or i'll never see my husband again
mr chairman while america is my country
kuwait is my home
life in kuwait before the invasion was
basically worry free we were treated
with respect dignity and compassion by
the emir and the kuwait government and
people
although you were expected to be
responsible for yourself
no one was expected to do without in
kuwait
kuwait is still providing for us
here while we are here until we can go
back
it's been difficult for me to express my
feelings since the iraqi invasion on
august the 2nd
terror confusion despair vulnerability
emptiness and anger are just a few of
the emotions i have felt since our world
was literally turned upside down
even during the iran iraq war when iran
terrorized the u.s embassy
in kuwait and held many of us hostage in
the american school where i worked where
we treated so badly
nothing like what is going on now in
kuwait
the primitive uncivilized behavior of
saddam hussein's forces was never
expected in a million years
a few months ago we could never imagine
the horrors that we have had to
experience in the last 60 days
the acts witnessed by many of us who
fled our homes go beyond what many would
consider even flagrant human right
abuses
it's clockwork orange in kuwait now and
chaos and mayhem have intruded into
every corner of our lives
some of the horrors are vivid and
they'll remain with me forever
i lived across the street from a school
which had been occupied in kuwait
it was occupied in the first weeks
during the invasion several days after
the invade several days after they took
over the school we heard screaming and
we went up to the second floor of the
house and you can look right down into
the school
there was a woman
and a small girl
and a man who was on the ground had his
hand
hands cuffed behind his back it was her
husband
they raped the woman and the child
then they shot the man in the head
the next day these tortures went on
daily the next day we seen boys brought
in
they were also handcuffed and put on
their knees
and they said that they the iraqis said
that they were in the resistance
and they held their eyes open and put
lit cigarettes
into their eyes
and after they finished that they shot
him
and we also seen them take one of the
resistance
and they took his pants down and took
broken coke bottles
and put up their backsides to get
information from them and when they
couldn't they shot him
the iraqi soldiers would come across the
street and knock on the doors to get
water or cigarettes or food or whatever
and at these times i would have to hide
in closets
because they said that they would kill
families wipe out whole families if you
were caught hiding a westerner or an
american in their homes
and it was terrifying it was just
it was the most horrible experience i've
ever experienced in my life
our cousin went into labor she was
pregnant and i went with my husband to
take her to sabah maternity hospital
where upon our arrival
there was a kuwaiti woman there she was
in hysterics
she was screaming and our car we was
coming up slowly because we needed to
get our cousin into the hospital
and this woman the soldiers
they took a bayonet and stuck it through
her stomach
and impelled her on a wall
where upon that time we took our cousin
home and delivered the baby ourselves
i can only ask
how these animals can commit such
barbaric and inhuman acts and then deny
that these acts ever took place
how can they purport to be part of a
civilian international community
when they commit uncivilized acts of
unspeakable brutality
when president bush likened saddam
hussein to adolf hitler it rang true to
me
although saddam hussein may not yet have
carried out an organized genocide
against the people of kuwait he
certainly is committing acts
against humanity of unimaginable
brutality
he is seeking to wipe the country off of
the map
and its people
in saddam hussein's campaign to iraqi
eyes kuwait he has taken the most basic
items necessary to life
and death
from kuwait patients prematurely
discharged from hospitals die from
exposure
inexplicable civilian deaths apparently
are caused by soldier reprisals
resistance casualties have left hundreds
dead
we have no way to prepare the citizens
for burials
because the mortuaries have been
pillaged and looted even the freezers
to rob someone of their life is not
it apparently has not been enough
stripping every shed of dignity and
respect seems to be the goal
this is both ghastly and goalish as well
as inhumane
i suppose we're all here to tell our
stories of dreadful and unthinkable acts
as distasteful as that job may be
frankly i wish
i could say that i didn't see anything
or that these things didn't happen
but they did
and i'll be forced to remember these
nightmares
of real life for the rest of my own life
in comparison to some i guess my first
hand experience may even be considered
mild or the norm since august 2nd
but i cannot escape the images of death
destruction brutality and helplessness
that these horrible scenes have been
printed upon my mind
it's important to step up and describe
what we've seen in kuwait
so that others may know an international
action and u s action can seek to
prevent further innocent bloodshed
i appreciate this opportunity to pay
tribute to those kuwaitis and
compatriots who have died and suffered
fighting this oppression there have been
profiles encouraged living with the
viper in their midst
and i must say that if something isn't
done soon these the kuwaitis just cannot
they won't last much longer if they
don't get help soon
deborah thank you
dr khalid al nasser
mr chairman
distinguished members of the caucus
thank you for holding this hearing today
my name is khalid al-nasar
i am a kuwaiti national
i'm currently staying in seattle
washington
both my undergraduate and postgraduate
work
has been done here
i spent several years studying in the
united states
after i have finished in 1979 i went to
kuwait
and i worked as the assistant professor
of medical
genetics and later in addition to my
profession
i was the vice dean for administration
and finance
for the kuwait university school of
medicine
12 years after the iraqi invasion
i escaped kuwait with my family
in a car caravan
crossing the desert to saudi arabia
the story of that morning
august the 14th
is one of emotional torture
ill-treatment and humiliation
to flee from the iraqi invaders
i took my wife
and my nine-year-old daughter
in the family car
and we met
at a predetermined
location
very early that morning at around 4 30
quarter to 5.
we met approximately 70 to 80
displaced kuwaiti families
our goal was to cross the desert
a mere feet in itself
and then enter to saudi arabia and reach
freedom
somewhere in the middle of the desert
we were intercepted by iraqi soldiers
the guide with about 10 other families
ahead of us
were able to escape the interception
[Music]
the iraqi soldiers
however got ahold of us
they forced us
out of our cars
by force
they searched us
in a miserable way
and they searched our belongings
they have verbally abused us
they detained interrogated us for some
time
and i feared first for my child
and my wife
as the iraqis became hysterical
when they thought a coat hanger in my
suitcase was a gun
in addition
i heard all the rumors of the atrocities
that were inflicted upon kuwaiti women
and children in that caravan
after the soldiers were satisfied with
their search however
they gave us the wrong directions
towards saudi arabia
and they let us go
it was probably their hope
that we would lose our way and die in
the
desert the cars behind our group saw
what happened to us
some of them threatened
and intimidated
they turned around and went back to
kuwait
i followed the iraqi soldiers directions
for about 600 yards or so
now this is a desert there is nothing in
it no roads
after that 600
yards and i could see the tank and the
soldiers
i had to veer to the right and go to
where i thought
the guide was heading
and sure enough we reached saudi arabia
now gentlemen
i know
of many extreme injustices committed
against the citizens of kuwait
many of them family members and friends
i saw the iraqis shoot at kids
i saw them kill a woman in a
demonstration she had a picture of the
emir and they killed her
i saw their indiscriminate firing from
their tanks at kuwaiti homes
my sister's home was destroyed by a tank
i saw them loot
and i saw them burn
supermarkets
the iraqis forced so many people
out of their homes and moved into them
i know three people
whose families were ousted by force
from their homes
i saw handcuffed kuwaitis
forced to lie face down on a highway of
black asphalt
at noon
where the temperatures must have
exceeded 170 degrees fahrenheit
iraqi soldiers continued to keep the
kuwaiti's face down on the pavement by
placing their feet
on their heads
i and my wife were witness to that and
my child
one close friend of mine a physician at
mubarak hospital
told me that three days after the
invasion
the iraqis converted his hospital
into military barracks
they installed snipers
on the roofs and soldiers infiltrated
the premises i saw the snipers
on the roof of mubarak hospital
the iraqis took all the patients
most of them sick and old
and forced them at gunpoint into the
hospital corridors
not in their beds into the ground on the
in the corridors
their rooms were evacuated to make room
for wounded iraqi soldiers
patients were viciously and deliberately
injured while they were being moved
and as i know blood transfusions were
prohibited
except for iraqi soldiers
half the patients in that hospital
died
because they were moved from their rooms
and removed from their life support
systems and machinery or because they
were denied medical treatment
the wounded civilians
and i no one who was wounded in his
right leg
were prohibited from receiving blood
transfusions
now the ill treatment of the sick
gentleman
is a severe violation
of all that is decent and just
many hospitals have been destroyed
the hospital
was ransacked
medical supplies beds equipment
everything was taken from that hospital
the shui hospital a primary care unit
and that's where i live
in that residential section was
completely demolished
all medicines
have been confiscated for the sole use
by the iraq by the iraqi soldiers
i am relieved
to see my family safe in the united
states
but i would welcome a return
to my home country
as a fellow kuwaiti
i stand before you
stunned by reports just being released
on the iraqi treatment of my countrymen
reports of civilians
men women and children
killed outside the context
of armed conflict
are almost unbelievable
except that i have seen the inhumanity
of this invasion firsthand
boys as young as 15 are shot for
punishment
as punishment for alleged opposition to
iraqi invasion
and methods of human torture raging from
rape to electric shock treatment to
prolonged beatings the breaking of limbs
and the extraction of finger and
toenails are commonplace
the invaders are criminals
i pray that
they may someday soon
stand trial for all these crimes
i urge you gentlemen to condemn the
extreme
intimidation
and the violent abuses of the iraqis
against my people
i urge you to stand fast against this
terror
thank you very much
thank you dr al-nassar
next
beth hankin
thank you mr chairman for this
opportunity to speak before you today
my name is beth hankin
and i'm an american from monticello iowa
and i'm married to a kuwaiti
my husband remains a captive in kuwait
prior to leaving kuwait september 8th on
the first u.s flight available
i was a schoolteacher at a secretary of
american school
a research assistant for a professor at
the university of kuwait
i also work for several private kuwait
companies
during my five years of residency in
kuwait city
from august 12th
to september 8th when i left kuwait
i lived in a nightmare
iraqi soldiers repeatedly
and arbitrarily fired outside my front
door
terrorism terrorizing myself
and everyone in the neighborhood
the cousin of a close friend was
brutally tortured for distributing
leaflets for the kuwaiti resistance
after being arrested by the iraqis
they broke his knuckles
ripped off his fingernails burned him on
several parts of his body
and as the
amnesty international report has
attested
he's just one of the many who suffered a
horrible unspeakable abuses
after the invasion i lived within a
stifling atmosphere of fear intimidation
the iraqis claimed it was legal to where
it was illegal to wear a beard in kuwait
since a beard signifies membership of a
religious sect
bearded men were given hopson's choice
the so-called option of shaving
in essence degrading their religious
beliefs or death
people going to the mosque to pray are
met with intimidation and violence
the iraqis have entered the mosque and
arrested the bearded religious men
one such man's dead body was eventually
found in pieces
children of kuwaiti western parents were
not allowed to leave kuwait even with a
parent
houses were searched frequently
iraqis found a gun the family was given
20 minutes to evacuate before iraqis
destroyed their home and possessions
similarly if the iraqis found one dead
iraqi soldier in the vicinity they would
bomb homes arbitrarily
all this is clearly reminiscent of
actions taken by hitler in the 1930s and
40s
it was chilling to be caught in this
horrifying web
an american companion of mine still
living in kuwait has a kuwaiti friend
who was forced to leave her home
permanently as punishment for resistance
fighting in her neighborhood
in the same neighborhood iraqis went
into the homes
and kidnapped children from their
parents
these children have disappeared
their parents fear that they are lost
forever
or much worse
beyond intimidation the iraqis have
inflicted violent atrocities against
kuwaiti citizens
in one incident i heard that a woman
looking for her son
was told to go to an area called salmia
when she arrived she saw several kuwaiti
dead men hanging
rather than dying from strangulation
they died from the bleeding of
castration
to protest against the one-month
anniversary of the occupation kuwaitis
went to the rus to shout for a national
call to prayer
the iraqis responded by shooting them
with guns
tanks flares
killing men women and children
mr chairman this is a personal tragedy
of enormous proportion
for thousands of kuwaitis and for all
those americans and others supporting
kuwait and upholding principle
i miss my husband desperately and pray
for his safety
ironically at this moment is a blessing
we did not have children since under
iraqi law
they would have been forced to remain
in occupied kuwait
thank you
thank you
thank you very much
our final witness is
also using an assumed name and again we
ask our friends in the media to respect
the need to for her to protect her
family
and we finally call on naira to testify
mr chairman and members of the committee
my name is naira and i just came out of
kuwait
my mother and i were in kuwait on august
2nd for a peaceful summer holiday
my older sister had a baby on july 29th
and we wanted to spend some time in
kuwait with her
i only pray that none of my 10th grade
classmates had a summer vacation like i
did
i may have worse sometimes i could be an
adult
that could grow up
quickly i saw happen to the children of
kuwait
and to my country has changed my life
forever
has changed the life of all kuwaitis
young and old
we are children no more
my sister with my five-day-old nephew
traveled across the desert to safety
safety
there was no milk available for the baby
in kuwait
they barely escaped when their car was
stuck in the desert desert sand and help
came from saudi arabia
i stayed behind and wanted to do
something for my country
the second week after an invasion i
volunteered volunteered at the aladdin
hospital
with 12 other women
who wanted to help as well
i was the youngest volunteer
other women were from 20 to 30 years old
while i was there i saw the iraqi
soldiers coming to the hospital with
guns
they took the babies out of the
incubators
took the incubators and left the
children to die on the cold floor
that was horrifying
i could not help but think of my nephew
who if born premature might have died
that day as well
after he left the hospital some of my
friends and i distributed flyers
condemning the iraqi invasion until we
were warned we might be killed if the
iraqi sauce
the iraqi sauce
reactors have destroyed everything in
kuwait
this they stripped the supermarkets of
food the pharmacies of medicine
the factories of medical surprise
supplies
ransacked their houses and tortured
neighbors and friends
i saw and talked to a friend of mine
after his torture and released by the
iraqis
he is 22 but he looked as though he
could have been an old man
the iraqis dunked his head into a
swimming pool until he almost drowned
they pulled out his fingernails and
applied electric shock to sensitive
private parts of his body
he was lucky to survive
if an iraqi soldier was found dead in a
neighborhood
they burned to the ground all the houses
in the general vicinity and would not
let firefighters come until
until the
only ash and rebel was left
the iraqis were making fun of president
bush and verbally and physically abusing
my family and me on our way out of
kuwait
we only did so because life in kuwait
became unbearable
they have forced us to hide bernard to
every everything identifying our country
and our government
i want to emphasize that kuwait is our
mother and then they are our father
we repeat
we repeated this on the roofs of our
houses in kuwait until the iraq is
beginning shooting at us
and we shall repeat it again
i'm glad i am 15 old enough to remember
kuwait before so damascus and destroyed
it and young enough to rebuild it thank
you mayor i thank you let me thank all
of our witnesses uh
we've uh
passed eight years
in the existence of the congressional
human rights caucus we've had scores of
hearings
about human rights abuses throughout the
world
and i know my co-chairman tom lantos
will join me
in telling you that we have never heard
in all this time
in all circumstances
a record of inhumanity and brutality
and sadism
as the ones that the witnesses have
given us
today
i don't know how
the
people of the
civilized countries of this world
can fail
to do everything within their power
to remove this
scourge
from the face of our earth
and the witnesses
by providing to us
eyewitness accounts
and reports
detailing
the conduct of the iraqi
soldiers
under the command of sudan hussein
have done a great service to their
country and to ours and to all countries
of the world
who must join together
and take whatever action may be
necessary
to free the people of kuwait
from this aggression and brutality
tom lentos
well let me first express my deepest
thanks to all of you
you have performed a
service of
incalculable value
and one can only hope and pray that
every american and indeed every citizen
of every civilized country
we'll hear your story
there are rare moments in history
when we are confronted with
human depravity of
incredible proportions
we had the killing fields in cambodia
we had the holocaust
with millions
innocent
killed
and now we have
the rape
of the people of kuwait
i do want to ask some questions
if you'll allow me
of
three members of the panel
ruth deborah and beth
because they represent to me
very fine
examples of young american women
were brought up in a free and open
and democratic society where human
rights are respected
and they were thrust into the nightmare
of
terrorist gang
engaging in actions
that we associate with
the dark moments of human history
so let me begin with you ruth if i may
where were you born
in memphis tennessee will you take a mic
and you went to elementary and high
school
in memphis
your brothers and sisters i have three
older sisters three older sisters
since you have come home
have you told them this story
yes sir what is their reaction
just it's so unbelieving for them to
realize that
that i lived through it they understand
what saddam hussein and his army are
capable of but it was
quite unbelievable for them to to
realize that their baby sister lived
through all of that and was able to get
out and tell the story
have you spoken to church groups or
other groups in in the community
yes sir i've been real active in memphis
with the world affairs council and
speaking to gifted children at several
schools and
i'm happy to do that
now ruth do people truly believe your
story not in the sense that they would
doubt your veracity but can they
comprehend
the enormity of the cruelty that you
were exposed to i think it's hard for
americans
we live so nice
in our country in america
to comprehend
the terrors
and the nightmares people suffered
i i can't answer that i know it's hard
to realize that people can do this to
other people
but the people in iraq
are capable of anything and everything
in the worst ways
and they've shown that to me
how they've treated the people in kuwait
and other foreigners there
best let me ask you this have you spoken
to to various groups in your community
where are you living now
i'm i live in monticello iowa with my
parents
and i have many people i when i first
came back i told people that i'd be
willing to come and speak to them about
my experiences and about what's
happening in kuwait
i've talked to various organizations
around eastern iowa
and also to socially conscious churches
and to many schools
may i come to you deborah
you um have
shaken up all of us
even those who have seen horror first
hand like myself
what has been your reception in in your
community where you live now when you
spoke of of your experiences
people have been reduced to tears they
just they can't
comprehend it i mean still
i've watched these things with my own
eyes and still i'm
sometimes i'm just just not convinced
that i really lived through all of that
that i made it and
every night i wake up in the middle of
the night i'm wondering are they doing
those things to my husband to his
families
you know so i've pretty well stayed away
from church and different things because
it's still hard for me myself to accept
but i got a very warm reception from the
people
i understand before we conclude i'd like
to call on my distinguished friend and
colleague from rhode island
thank you mr chairman
uh i too
greatly appreciate your strength and
your courage and and your willingness to
testify here today
too often
the world disbelieves
the atrocities that occur
they wish to live a fantasy to think
that the world is a very peaceful place
and that somehow these things never
occur
and it's only through
words and testimony that you've provided
here
that we can help to make people who are
idealistic realist
and that we can then create that realism
into some foreign policy which hopefully
can prevent
this
continued atrocity in the world
i certainly as a human being
find it difficult to understand how we
can continue to sit and just permit
the continued atrocities of someone who
has obviously forfeited the right to be
called a human being saddam hussein
he has permitted as the head of his
country
atrocities which none of us can
comprehend fully
because those of us who sit here have
not experienced the enormousness of the
horrors that go with those sort of
atrocities
perhaps
your testimony
will be the basis for this country
waking up to understanding that we are
not immune
just because
we are across the ocean
from this sort of human rights abuse
that our citizens
still remain in that country
that we have by some estimates 3 000
people
who this very moment may be
terrorized and tortured
by this very uh
inhuman
regime
and so you have done a service not just
to kuwait
but for all mankind because we must tell
the world
of the enormousness of what is going on
we appreciate and thank you very much
it was
51 years ago
that adolf hitler unleashed
unspeakable horrors on
mankind and the initial reaction of
vast numbers
was one of this belief
[Music]
or lack of interest
saddam hussein
has now unleashed on the people of
kuwait
unspeakable horrors
he is ready to unleash unspeakable
horrors
to other nations in the area
and it is the responsibility of all of
us
to awaken a
an indifferent
and disinterested
world community
to what this new hitler means
with your
presence and with your courageous and
moving testimony you have done mankind a
major service
the congressional human rights caucus if
it has done nothing in the last eight
years
but bring this one hearing
to the attention of the american people
it has served its purpose
i want to thank all of you this hearing
is concluded
[Music]
that concludes this hearing on alleged
human rights violations in kuwait for
further information you may contact the
congressional human rights caucus in
washington dc the zip code is 20515
coming up in just a moment live coverage
of the united states senate
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you